so as of 2007 4
million dna profiles on the uk database
5 million plus profiles on the united
states database worldwide so most
countries now have a national database
well why we've now got about 12 million
plus people
mainly criminals logged into those
databases
enormously powerful tool in the fight
against crime
so in england and wales if you have a
crime scene sample that yields dna
simply by looking up on the database
you'll find your prime suspect
in around about 53 54
of cases in scotland it's up at 68
percent
quite remarkable so this is this is a
shortcut
if you'd like to a lot of police
investigative work get your dna
you're probably going to essentially
solve the case on the spot
so the impact is extraordinary major
impacts on detection rates in volume
crime
like car theft and burglary a detection
rate is shot right up
thanks to availability of dna what we're
now seeing
and there are various international
conventions have been drawn up
which now allow information to be
compared between national dna databases
so both the g8 countries and separately
interpol have established protocols
whereby
you know you've got a crime in britain
that you can't solve well
maybe you've got a sneaky feeling it
might be a dutch person or something
like that or vice versa
so you start exchanging information and
see if you get matches outside your
country
and a number of really quite serious
offences have been solved
by exactly that approach